what's up believe nation welcome to
another AMA it's part of my commitment
on Thursdays to try to be here for you
answer questions either solo by myself
or having a guest on with me today we're
doing and ask me anything
episode number ten so welcome everybody
please leave your questions in the
comments tag me it's a lot easier for me
to see them and let's dive in so the
first question I got is coming in from
Chris Young hi Evan just want to just
want to keep on telling you thank you
for amazing content feeling the love man
my question is how do you define hard
work and smart work so let me start with
the smart work cuz that's easier smart
work I just think is minimizing the
number of inputs to get the output that
you want to get the result you want
you're trying to go and complem goal or
dream and what a base we looking at is
to get that result what kind of time
money effort resources am i putting into
it and working smartly means you're
reducing the number of inputs to get the
same output or an even better output and
so your Modlin success your trial and
error you're always continuing to make
better versions to use technology to
leverage knowledge and information to
help you work more efficiently working
harder is more interesting I think
that's a personal definition I think
it's so easy for us to look at other
people and say well that person's
working really hard you might look at
what I do on my youtube channel and say
making it three videos a day is really
hard or when I'm filming and I'm making
you know 30 40 50 videos in a day you
might look at that and say that's really
hard and I don't see that necessarily as
my definition of hard work I think for
me hard work is more when you don't feel
like getting up and doing the thing that
you need to do you get up and do it
anyway it's easy for me to come on and
do tons of videos in one day I love
doing it I'm surprised at how quickly
the time flies by so I don't consider
that to be really hard work but for the
days that things aren't going right for
the days that I'm struggling for the
days that I don't have the confidence to
the ability or whatever still getting up
and doing it as an example
earlier this week I had a really bad
night of sleep I went to bed at 11:00
and I woke up at 3:30 which is crazy for
me I don't usually have that big swing
so I woke up I started working if for
anybody who follows me on snapchat
Instagram you would have seen the post
come out and at 7:30
you know I'm four hours into my work
they're ready and I got music blasting
them jumping them I'm in the zone
come 4:30 in the afternoon
I'm certain to crash really hard really
badly and I you know recommendation go
get a nap go sleep for me when I nap
during the day it just totally messes up
my my evening I don't sleep well and so
I just kept going that I gotta consider
hard work when you don't want to go when
you don't have the energy when you're
low on sleep when something went wrong
that's what I consider to be hard work
because it's actually hard it's not just
a number of hours that you're putting in
it's that it's actually difficult for
you to do not from a skill perspective
but from a mental and emotional energy
perspective it's difficult that's what I
think is hard next what do we got leave
some questions tag me easier for me to
see what do we got thank you so much
this is Marwa thank you so much you
really helped change my life I can't
find your book in any book stores and
Dubai unfortunately when will it be
available I have no idea I think the
easiest way is just to order it online
for for your one word it's up to the
publisher what markets we hit
internationally and for the top ten
rules I publish it through Amazon so I
don't know that it's in any bookstores
or if they are it's really limited so
Amazon is your best friend hopefully you
can find it we've had people from Dubai
I've had people emailing the receipts
from Dubai so people are buying it there
just go to Amazon who's your best friend
Salima how do you handle unexpected
things that come that derail you that
derail your to do for the day
one I expect it don't expect great
things to be happening every single day
and everything you know is gonna be
amazing and you're not gonna have any
problems I expect there to be chaos and
problems every single day I have a
series of things that I tell myself
every morning and one of them is that
I'm gonna be great even with all of the
chaos that is likely to happen and so I
think when your expectations are of
something else to happen then what
actually happens then you get the press
then you get down then it's easy to fall
off the wagon and why that's so
dangerous is because it's it then often
spirals out of control for the rest of
your day maybe the rest of your week you
know if you have a bad Monday start of
the day then it's easy to just give up
on the Monday and give up on the week
and say I'm gonna start again tomorrow
I'm gonna start again next Monday that's
super dangerous just because one thing
didn't go according to plan
and so I expect things not to go to plan
I've tried to adopt the mindset that
when something is hard or when something
is tougher when there's a problem that
it's good and that I that I'm excited by
it that these challenges I don't welcome
into my life and that I'm not trying to
seek them out but when they come I'm
ready to tackle them head on and it's
and it's good and then that and just
surrounding myself with people who who
build me up you know my videos the book
like all of these people face insane
challenges likely a much bigger
challenge than whatever got you derailed
for the day and so being around that
makes me remember that the problem I'm
facing right now it's not that big a
problem and I need to be able to solve
it to get to where I want to go I think
that really helps apt em hi from Russia
can you please give me advice on how to
learn English thank you for your videos
this always hits home for me because my
mother came from Italy she didn't speak
any English she landed here in Canada
and she learned English through watching
TV programs and if you spoke to her
you wouldn't know that she was from
Italy she has zero accent she's got you
know PhDs and she learned English by
watching TV shows and a lot of people
have written into me saying they learn
English by watching my videos which is
crazy it's kind of a full-circle moment
for me I would if you were trying to
learn a language I would try to learn
something that you are generally curious
about so it forces you to want to look
up what those words are so if you really
want to be a gamer or you really want to
be an entrepreneur or I really want to
be a youtuber it's gonna be a whole
bunch of words that are used regularly
like if you got the chance to interview
or to be on a hangout like this or to
watch videos with your favorite youtuber
gamer and that's something you really
want to do you're gonna care about every
single word that they say like if they
have a whole census that you don't
understand you're gonna want to look up
all those words so that you really get
it and so when you're learning something
that is really interesting for you it's
gonna stick or if you're just reading a
language book like here the here's verb
structure and here's here's the you know
the nouns that you need to know and
adjectives that still works
it's just takes a lot more discipline a
lot more effort compared to being able
to watch and learn the thought the stuff
that you love so if I was you if I was
Russian and I was trying to learn
English
this helps so watching a stream like
this asking a question if I said
something you don't understand go look
it up watching some of the videos that I
put out if you love Steve Jobs or Oprah
Winfrey or whoever it is that we
profiled watch more of their videos
because you're learning about yourself
you're learning a new skill that you
want to go off and develop and you're
learning the language at the same time I
think learning learning anything as a
language I'm getting heavy into
Instagram recently I want to I want to
update my Instagram game I changed my
profile picture across all my platforms
but I spend a lot more time at Instagram
than I ever had before
just trying to have a bigger impact and
learning that is language learning what
the post learning the frequency learning
do I put words on it or not learning the
hashtag culture learning how to do
responses all of that stuff is
language and it doesn't seem like work
because I'm interested in it and so
you're much more likely to learn when
you're interested in it think about what
you learn growing up in school most of
it you forget because you didn't care
about it you don't use it it wasn't
interesting for you you just did it to
pass a test where the stuff that you
actually deeply cared about you still
remember and so tying your English
language learning into a skill or task
that you're generally excited about will
help you pick it up a lot more quickly
what do we got Zachary Evan how do you
work on procrastination that's funny how
do you work on procrastination instead
of delaying procrastination a couple
things one make sure you have a goal
that's exciting for you I think a lot of
people procrastinate because they have
goals that are not inspiring you're
doing stuff you hate and you can only
force yourself to do something that you
don't like for so long before you give
up
put it off and so finding the thing that
you love now it's still there might be
something that somebody else hates you
might look at step into my schedule and
say man to make three videos a day
that's torture great don't do that
go do something else right me jumping
into whatever you want to do would feel
like torture and a lot of work and I'd
want to put that off as much as possible
too
so first off is having goals that are
really meaningful and important to you
doesn't mean everything is easy there's
still a lot of hard work that goes
alongside it but I think having
meaningful goals will really really help
you next is creating the morning habits
routines environment to build you up
it's easy when you are an employee and
you have a boss who's telling you
exactly what to do and if you don't get
the work done you get fired right so you
have to get it done you're accountable
entrepreneurs we're not accountable
anybody who are we accountable to nobody
and so that's a big problem if you're
not accountable to anybody but yourself
we are much more likely to let ourselves
down than to let somebody else down and
so if you can create some habits and an
environment of Rutina supports you so
for me I walk into here right like I see
these people this inspires me I read a
page from from the book my top ten rules
every single day it inspires me to want
to think bigger to push harder because
it's easy to get lazy you know my wife
Nina isn't pushing me to be a better
entrepreneur my son Hayden isn't pushing
me to be a better entrepreneur I need to
push myself and so to do that I get
inspired by all these successful people
who have done big things because I want
to do something bigger so that's what I
suggest have more important goals and
create a morning routine and environment
that supports you what else
Mischa hey Ivan thanks for buying my
side Lily are you interested in a
segment for new entrepreneurs
cool first off Lily's awesome I'm glad
that that she helped you you got some
value from that interested in this
segment for new entrepreneurs I don't
know what you mean by that
if it's profiling new entrepreneurs
up-and-coming potentially I think for
every new series so here's what I
here's how we determine a new series on
YouTube there are some series that I do
just because I want to just because I
love it like this series here this AMA
series will probably lose more
subscribers for me than gain but I do it
because I want to provide value to you
guys I want to help I want to be a
resource I enjoy and hopefully it
touches you guys and you ask a question
and and leverage it in your life in your
business I wish something like this
existed when I was getting started in my
company to have somebody to ask
questions to some of the other series
like life with Evan you know I can't on
to lose subscribers because it's not in
the sale or everybody signed up for if
you will came for a top ten series but I
think it's really important that in all
of your content strategy you have some
personal content it's likely going to be
the least performing content on any of
your channels but if people feel like
they know you
those are gonna be your superfans and
then when you need to sell something or
you need a favor you need help on doing
something those are the people the ones
who feel like they really connect with
you those are the people are gonna buy
your book buy your merch sign up for
your newsletter you know go into your
coaching program whatever the thing is
that you're trying to get them to take
action on and so I think you need to
have at least 10 to 20% of your content
be personal nature apart from that the
other series we look at are they
generating growth for the business are
they leading to subscribers are they
leading to watch time the two key
metrics that I look at from a YouTube
perspective so is this helping me grow
my channel is it reaching a big audience
I'm not super interested in having
videos that reach 20 people right it's
not why I do this I want to have a big
impact and now I want to do it in a
positive way if I did a video on the 10
stupidest things you know Kanye West has
ever said I'm sure that video would
explode and do well but that's not the
mission that that I'm all about so we're
not promoting negativity we're not
making fun of people it's trying to
spread belief and so with that in mind
spreading believe helping people believe
in themselves
and what new series can I come up with
that will lead to more growth lead to a
big impact and so we trade off of
celebrity name a lot people who are well
known you know if I did a Steve Jobs
video it'll do better than I did up and
coming you know Nev mobs video hahaha
but sometimes the story itself can be
amazing so that's that's always a
trade-off if I do somebody who is
well-known if I do an Elon Musk and
Oprah Winfrey or Steve Jobs we know that
it will have an impact which is really
what I'm trying to do if I do somebody
who is unknown then the story needs to
be so good because there is no you know
celebrity factor to it that it makes it
the series more difficult to create but
that being said I'm open to it and I'm
open to being able to continue to expand
the series we just did a girlboss series
I think that was last week and we're
looking at doing reaching out into the
black community in the Latin community
still come up with names
looking at either black excellence in
Viva but I'm open to other names for the
series and it's constantly looking at
and evaluating every single series we
have back to the first question but
working smarter every single series that
we have we're constantly looking at the
numbers is it working
are we getting the best results possible
can we adjust should we kill this series
we just killed off three different
series maybe four earlier this week so
you'll notice some changes coming on the
channel and that's part of growth what
do we have
Salima Evan please share tips and your
prose of wisdom on publishing a book
self publishing a book so I've done both
I self-published the top ten rules and I
went with penguin Random House for your
one word if you're gonna sell publish a
couple things to keep in mind one you
have to do everything yourself so I
would find somebody who you can bounce
ideas off of or an editor or somebody
that you can you know kind of proofread
your work one of the greatest parts
about going with
a big company is that they have the
editors they take care of all the
details we still haven't launched the
Kindle version the eBook version we're
getting close we're close we're close
it's the most requested email I think I
get do you have a Kindle version yet no
the formatting is ridiculous it's
ridiculous and so you will have to take
on a lot of that work or hire somebody
who who knows how to do that and can do
it for you
apart from that is you get the template
you know if you're going with great
space is what I use Amazon's service you
get the template you download it you
make sure the formatting is OK you write
the book and you upload it it's not that
part's not the most complicated thing in
the world
my recommendation though is you need to
start building an audience it's because
it's really on you to sell the book even
if you're with a big publisher it's
still on you to sell the book but this
is gonna be on you to sell the book and
a lot of authors only focus on writing
the book and they're not building up
their audience they're not building up a
customer base until they've launched the
book and then they realize just nobody
that I know that I can sell it to beyond
my friends and family and so you sell 20
copies and all that hard work that went
into the book doesn't doesn't bear fruit
like as a as a writer you want your book
to be seen you want it to be in people's
hands you want the message that you have
to touch people's lives and so what I'd
recommend is doing a a journey of so as
you're creating it you take people on
your journey and you show people what
you're doing and why it's important and
you you're documenting the process so I
did that with the first book I did it
with the second book to a smaller degree
I think that's really really really
really really really important the most
important part is so publishing a book
is thinking about the market inside how
you're gonna build an audience not just
creating the content where most authors
get stuck they don't even think about
until it's out if you think writing the
book is hard marketing it is even harder
next the lot the lot Jay Evan is
blogging still viable for reputation
building yes if I was blogging though I
would so if you're blogging then you
have a talent
- right right and if that if that's what
you're really good at I would be looking
at how else can I use that that talent
I'd be looking at Twitter I'd be looking
at medium I'd be looking at Facebook how
can I create some of that content and
get that get it out there LinkedIn if
you're in a b2b environment as well I
think just writing the blog and just
relying on kind of Google - SEO your
your traffic and send you people is it
still works but it's limited because
people are getting there people are
spending their time on lots of places
now I'm not just going to Google to
search for things and so I would be
looking at if you're a blogger great how
can you take that blog post that you
spent lots of time working on and maybe
it's a thousand words and then how can
you take three of those sentences and
put them as three different Twitter
posts and how can you take a paragraph
of it and put it up on LinkedIn or on
Facebook some of the core messages I
think that's I think you would get more
juice from the squeeze by doing that I
think you could still have success just
writing the blog it's just harder it's
not working smarter right back to the
first question if you want to work
smarter take the stuff that you've
already done
so it's example what I'm doing on my
Instagram a lot of the quotes we're
pulling from the videos that we're doing
so I do a video posted on YouTube we
take a quote we post out to Instagram
every morning I do a welcome message to
you guys believe nation and I put it on
my it started off just put into my
snapchat stories and today I was talking
about your genius you know you are a
genius don't let people and don't let
yourself tell you that you are not and
stop feeling that you can't solve this
problem you are a genius so I go on just
you know 15-second rant and I post at
the snapchat and then I'll post it to
Facebook stories I posted to my
Instagram stories I'll save it as a
video post it to my Twitter with a quick
explanation of what I'm saying then
we'll take that quote and that'll be
turned into a picture that's gonna go
live on Instagram it's gonna go live on
Twitter it's gonna go live on my
Facebook page you'll see that
three thirty ish Eastern and so being
able to multi-purpose use your ideas and
all the work that you're creating can
really help you it can help you work a
lot smarter because you put so much the
problem I see is you put so much time
into making this blog making this
beautiful piece of content that I want
people to see it I want people to hear
your message and for a little bit extra
work you could have a lot of exposure in
different areas driving people to your
site what do we got what do we got what
do we got what we got
posh notions that's what I'm doing right
now documenting yeah documenting your
journey is super important I think if
you if you are an expert at something
then you can do videos you can you can
share your expertise but you're also
always becoming right even if you are
great at something you're still becoming
a better version you're still becoming
something else and so documenting that
process to show your journey is super
important and and it's very human entice
people to you where if you're only
coming at them as an expert then they
like you they know you but what they
feel your vulnerabilities and what
you're trying to learn then it really
ties them to you another way is to
interview people you know if you if you
want to be an author start interviewing
successful authors and make that as
content and you you get to build an
audience of people who want to be
authors and are getting value so your
journey is not just where you've gone
and what you've learned but it could
involve interviewing other people
showcasing their knowledge and talents
and helping you build your audience up
at the same time to Mike John do you
have bad habits Evan I think everybody
has bad habits I think it's just what
you consider to be bad I think I am I am
I'm solid 90% of the time but in those
in that 10% is is where I'm not happy
and what I need to fix so as an example
not that long ago I told my wife and I
told the people on my team if you hear
me complaining I want you to call me out
on it and almost by default everybody's
action or their response was well you
when you don't complain I don't hear
your complain
and that's not true you know it's not
that I never complain I try my best not
to and see the opposite side and try to
see how we can solve it and how it's an
opportunity for us but there's still
that 10% of the time that I may not
catch myself and I need help kind of
calling me out on it
same thing for for working you know I
talked about working hard and what that
means you know if I'm up at 3:30 I only
had four and a half hours sleep and I'm
you know working and then I start
crashing at 3:30 4:30 in the afternoon
90% of the time I'll keep working my way
through it and ten percent of the time
I won't ten percent of time I'll let
myself down if I'm sticking to a diet
you know I've got my I've got my lentils
right here lentils and barley tea you
know I'm sticking to that but ten
percent of the time I don't and whether
it's ten percent or five percent of 12
percent you know I think in general we
are never a hundred percent of who we
want to be is a constant it's a constant
growth and I think having other people
to help hold you accountable makes it a
lot easier there's no one like super bad
habit that I have that I can think of at
least it's more I'm only 90 percent on
the places that I want to be 99 percent
on so I'm working on it
what else just it Sultan how many times
will be such live broadcast per week or
per month so if we're looking at this on
my channel I'm I'm trying to do once a
week I look at Thursday in this time
spot 11 o'clock either for half an hour
an hour or somewhere in between there
Thursday is always my public-facing day
so I do interviews and hangouts and
meetings so this is a great example back
to the first question working hard so I
started today woke up at 7:00 got right
to work checked in and all the things
you need to check in on touch base with
my team and all the important things
that are happening posted some new
content that we needed to get out had a
meeting with Alex who came over and then
I got into this and after this I'm doing
another four or five hangouts and then I
have a group of entrepreneurs coming
over in my Toronto mastermind and we're
gonna go till 10:30
that none of that seems like work you
know like that that's all fun this is
fun
for some people step into that schedule
they might think wow that's insane
that's crazy I want to do that but for
me it's super fun but back to the
question about the live interviews my
goal is to have it once a week to be
here provide value for you guys as long
as you're enjoying you know I'm not I'm
not attached to it if if you guys are
saying you know what Evan this is this
is crap we don't want to hear your
opinions we don't have questions for you
then then I'll stop it I'll feel hurt
for five minutes and then like okay the
people have spoken I'm gonna go off and
do something else with this time this is
this is probably the in terms of time
for impact the least efficient use of my
time
I just enjoy it and I hope that even
though I'm talking to a few people that
it's having it's important that like by
having the one-on-one it makes you think
and makes you make some changes in your
life
Mia Evan I work with moms and my one
word is shine I love that Sandra my
assistant my personal assistant her one
word is shine too if you ever see shine
on some of the comments it's it's her
writing in do you have any more ideas
and getting them pumped up about self
about self and shine when it's linked to
being a parent I work with moms I wanted
to shine do you have any more ideas and
getting them pumped up about self and
shine when it's linked to being a parent
I'm having a little bit of difficulty
with that question I would say one
parents especially moms like just care
so much about parenting it's it's a huge
source of pride and also a source of
guilt and that you feel like and I mean
speaking from the father's side you know
I've got hate in there you always feel
like you're not doing the right thing
and you always question where to go I
think the biggest thing around this
whole thing is judgment I think I think
there's always a concern around how
other parents will judge you how other
people will judge you that you're not
doing it the right way
you're not doing it like them and and
then their opinions of how you're
raising your kid start to seep into
yourself and you think maybe I'm doing
the wrong thing and that's really
dangerous because you don't have a lot
of confidence especially the first time
through you don't know how it's all
gonna play out right like you just don't
know maybe playing Mozart while while
your kid is in your belly
is actually gonna help them when they're
18 and studying for their exams or maybe
it'll hurt them you don't know and so
you're you because you don't have the
confidence and it's it's hard to have
the confidence then it's easy to fall
prey to the judgments of other people so
if I was looking at a group of moms what
I would try to lean into is
self-awareness for them self-awareness
for their kids I think the most
important thing you can teach is
confidence and self-awareness and kids
growing up and not judging their
responses I think if you can create an
environment where people feel welcomed
and not judged for what they're doing or
what they're saying then they're more
willing to share then they're more
willing to open up then they're more
willing to listen to a person
development message if you're trying to
get people to understand their one word
as an example the most important thing
to coach people through a one word
exercise is not judging their one word
not saying that that's a good word or
that's a bad word they're seeking your
approval and this is a personal exercise
it doesn't matter what I think it
matters what you think matters what you
think of you because only you understand
who you are at the core so trying to
create as open and non-judgmental and
environment as possible whether that's
in a group setting or just you
one-on-one I think is super important
next I use what is more important
planning their execution should I keep
finding the perfect plan or execute on
whatever plan
I have even if it's not good so the
answer is gonna be both but I spend you
know 95% of my time executing and 5%
planning I think I think you need to
have both but I think too many people
spend too much time on the planning mode
and I did too
I was always locked in planning about I
think people
are scared and people end up being
perfectionist because they're scared
when I had my first company was 19 years
old and I wanted to make the perfect
business plan before launching before
getting out there and we need to have a
perfect business plan because I might
make mistakes and I ended up losing a 40
million dollar deal because of it and
that taught me an important lesson that
you got to go you know you got to do
stuff and so I think if you wake up
every single day and you don't know what
you're doing I think I think you're not
working smart back to the first question
I don't think you're working smart I
think I think you need to wake up and
know what you're about to do and then go
off and do it I think 95 percent of time
should be spent executing now the five
percent of planning is super important
but if you're spending ninety five
percent of your time planning and only
five percent executing you're not being
efficient with your time you're losing
the winners are out there because
they're doing and so five percent of
time planning I'd be looking at whether
that's I don't have a regular schedule
for planning for me it's just when I
when I feel like I need it when
something is out of whack you know if I
want to introduce something new into my
life great that comes at the expense of
something now so I need to cut that
other thing to bring this new thing in
and I need to sit down and figure out my
schedule or if I'm feeling overwhelmed
or if I'm feeling bored then I have to
sit down and do a tweak but I'm
constantly changing my schedule at least
once a month I'm changing something in
my schedule but then most of the other
time about they're doing so I know what
I'm doing today I don't have to spend 3
hours in the morning thinking about what
my plan is gonna be for today right if
you're feeling overwhelmed and
frustrated and unhappy then it's worth
spending a day to sit down and figure
out your plan or a week or well however
whatever it takes but then then you're
out executing then you're doing so you
need both but 95% execution what else
what else what else have fees Hafeez
Evan how do you keep excitement through
the journey to achieve your goal you
have to enjoy the journey
you get excitement because you enjoy
doing the work that's the honest truth
if you look at the people have gone off
and done amazing things they have a goal
it's important goals are important but
more important than the goal is actually
enjoying the process if your only goal
is I want to make a million dollars or I
want to have a million YouTube
subscribers or whatever your goal is if
you don't enjoy the process of getting
there you're gonna quit
you just will unless it's such a small
goal unless it's like tomorrow I'm not
gonna eat junk food or you know tomorrow
I'm gonna lose half a pound you know you
have to you have to enjoy the process of
doing it otherwise you won't get there
so for me for YouTube I like I like
making videos I like it it's fun this is
fun all my interviews today it's all fun
I love it will it help me achieve my
goal I hope so but it's fun doing it I
like the challenge
I like the climb and if you watch my top
10 videos you'll see that comes up over
and over and over and over and over
again you have to love what you do you
have to enjoy the climb and so if you
find yourself not enjoying the work
you're sunk like go do something else
the minute you stop and join the work
like I was having a conversation
yesterday with with a longtime viewer
subscribe to the channel been around not
quite for the beginning of it pretty
close and we're talking about when when
I would stop doing YouTube like it'll
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen I
will stop doing YouTube one day and
it'll be it'll likely just be a okay
guys thank you for the love it's been an
amazing run ten years twenty years
whatever it is I'm moving on the other
things I threw away my website if you
guys go to my website right now it's a
bunch of pictures and at least it's a
little worked out more than when I first
launched it but I had I had a hundred
thousand pages on my website content
like crazy was making money from the
website and I just decided I'm not into
this anymore I'm gonna switch it we're
going down a new path what does it look
like I don't know yet I'm discovering
so that will happen at some point on
YouTube when I stopped liking it when
this becomes work when it's oh gotta go
and do an AMA with with the audience
when it becomes that I'm done I'm out
that's not happening as soon as I get an
inkling of that I'm gonna move on to
something else it kind of scares me even
a little bit that that I'm into
Instagram recently so much that I that I
check the updates and the stats and the
how things are working as much on
Instagram now as I am on YouTube YouTube
till still takes way more of my time
just way more cuz making video content
is a lot more work than just making a
post for Instagram but it's interesting
how it's it's consuming more of my my
free brain time to thinking how can I
make things better now don't worry I'm
not I'm not gonna abandon YouTube and go
all-in on Instagram but something like
that is gonna happen and I'll just stop
and and what will not stop is the desire
to help entrepreneurs like I love
helping you guys I want to have a big
impact I don't see that going away ever
it'll just be playing a bigger game
every single time so if you don't if you
don't like the process of achieving your
goal change like immediately you will
never do great things doing work that
you hate you'll never win doing work
that you hate the people who love doing
that work will crush you so go find work
that you love so you can win because you
have you have talent you have Michael
Jordan level talent that's something
that you could be the best in the world
at go do that and stop trying to be a
dr8 somebody else what else we got
people are linking up the Instagram
account Jay Rhys I appreciate it
what else what else I see a bunch of
comments tagged me it's a lot easier to
see kapal Evan sir people are hazy goals
people have are hazy and as you told
them many of your top 10s how to
overcome social anxiety
okay so how do overcome social anxiety
really comes down to just your own self
confidence your own level of of
self-love you know that you are a great
person my post today that's that's going
up on Instagram soon Twitter is you are
a genius like recognize that you are a
genius you are amazing
now it doesn't mean that you know
everything you still suck you still have
a lot to learn but you're also great and
know that you're great and at some point
you need to decide whose life you're
gonna live your version or what society
wants you to do now there's some rules
of society you know if you kill somebody
you get you have to deal with the
consequences going against what society
wants there are consequences right you
know if you want to go do something and
your parents don't want you to do it you
might get kicked out of the house you
can't complain about that like you have
to live with the consequences
but what's the alternative the
alternative is you just live a life that
everybody else wants you to live and you
never do anything great so what do you
prefer what everybody wants is the easy
road what everybody wants is for it to
be handed to them you want your parents
to support you you want your society to
support you you want it to be easy to go
off and chase your path and be great but
it's not so stop complaining about it
and make a decision you either live the
life that everybody around you wants you
to live and you hit you're happy with
that you decided that's okay or you're
gonna live your version and that's gonna
be a harder road and you deal with the
consequences I think once you've decided
that staying on that path the way to do
it is is again through environment I be
I think for me watching the videos on my
channel making them has boosted my
confidence has made me want to think
bigger I mean it's hard not to if you're
if you're watching content from Elon
Musk it's hard not to want to think
bigger yourself it's hard not to want to
play
and level game it's just hard like
you're just going to if you are around
people who are thinking big you're going
to think bigger and if you're around
people who hate their life guess what
you're gonna hate your life too and so
eliminating the negative people from
your life as much as possible or living
and exposure and then surround yourself
with people who are doing big things and
again if you don't know anybody doing
big things you don't need to know them
you know I don't I don't
I only know the people in the middle
here those are my parents and that's me
when I was eight right I've never met
the other people in my wall but I've
learned from them and they inspire me on
a regular basis and so surrounding
yourself with the people who have defied
social norms and what culture wants you
to do is important next st st r st r KR
streaker stalker streaker let's go
streaker what's your view on the phrase
hack hacking your reality what do you
think of biohacking nootropic drug
supplement so I am not the expert on on
I don't even know what nootropic is I
don't really take a lot of drugs or
supplements I'm a fan of biohacking I
like testing about a whole bunch of new
things I'm on my trampoline like I use a
stand-up desk long before it was cool to
use a stand up desk and I like the
rebounding now because it's it's uh it
has some health benefits to it so I love
I love I love trying out new things I
don't know about get into the drug side
though maybe a little too experimental
for me and I don't know what new topic
is but I feel like jr. eyes might and
he's gonna now tell me about it when he
comes over tomorrow next Mike hey Evan
would you consider someone's word a
brand yeah a brand is a feeling a brand
is not a logo a brand is a feeling when
you look at this brand you feel
something right so if you think about
what's a big brand if you think about
Lamborghini you feel something what do
you feel
if you think about McDonald's you feel
something else what do you feel and so
at the end of the day it's the value of
the company and so same thing your one
word is your ultimate core value and the
more you can articulate it and the more
you can put it out the easier people
will resonate with it so - believe
believe hopefully comes out of every
piece of content that I share comes out
of everything that I'm making on my
website on social media in every
interview that I do in every speech and
every book that I write and it's not
just me saying believe it's the feeling
through everything is that believe pours
through everything I make and so you
guys hopefully believe in yourselves a
little bit more after you are around
anything that I make whether that's a
one-on-one interview or a book or piece
of content that's what the brand is to
me at the beginning when I started this
I only thought entrepreneurs would
consume my content why would somebody
who is not an entrepreneur want to watch
stuff about entrepreneurship I'd say at
least half of my audience is not
entrepreneurs right now because they're
coming for the belief they're coming for
the confidence
they're coming for that little hit so
that they can now take that to their
life back to their job or back to their
relationship and so that's where bran
can go beyond just a specific niche or a
specific industry so absolutely your one
work to be a brand J rise wim hof
biohacking for the win yeah that's true
so wim hof that's a big one you can on J
rise to bring up the to resurface the
Buried content I was sick all the time
guys if you if those of you hardcore
fans who've been with me for a long time
you'll notice on the old videos how much
I was sick is that Evan is sick at the
bottom on a lot of videos and I just
decided was it last year early last year
I think so that I wasn't gonna get sick
and I researched wim HOF and he had the
ice baths and breathing techniques and I
applied that and also just a mindset
I think - and I've gotten I got sick
once last year so biohacking go look up
wim HOF we did some great videos on him
- it kind of explains it
next streaker again did you read the
book mastery do you recommend the book
for mastery I haven't read it I feel
like I have it it sounds familiar maybe
just maybe just a friend who wrote it so
I don't know I couldn't I couldn't
recommend it I'm a slow reader talk
about skills or habits I'm working on
I'm a slow reader and I don't spend a
lot of time on it I can actually read
quickly I just don't give it enough time
at night
I haven't placed enough importance on it
and I'm not 100% sure that I want to so
that's why I haven't so I don't I don't
have a lot of good book recommendations
to you because it takes me a long time
to go through a book if I'm only reading
for you know 10 minutes a night so maybe
maybe fellow believe nation members can
suggest some books on mastery for you
Mike thanks for that really helped
awesome Joanne my one word is start what
did you feel after you uploaded your
first video for this channel did it
scare you excite you I'm curious all the
best
ooh what did I feel after I said in my
first video probably a mix of everything
the first video I think is the Walt
Disney video way back I feel like I
actually had some others before that but
I deleted them which which upsets me
because I would love to see the journey
although the Walt Disney one is so bad
anyway that it's awesome to go back and
watch ah
I had my friend come in and film it with
me he is he runs a video production
company's name is mark Drager Franta
media there in the book million dollar
plus business now
he was just getting started I felt super
awkward and nervous recording the video
I'm wearing a suit I'm sitting down I
hate sitting down when I'm talking I'm
trying to memorize the script that I had
written out it's just all awkwardness
everywhere it's it's great
you should go go and watch it just to
have a laugh um I was excited when it
went up I promoted on my website so at
the time my website was you know I had a
popular website so I put it in the
sidebar and it got tens of thousands of
views I forget what it's at right now I
haven't looked at it for a while
yeah I was nervous I was excited I was
all of that I was I was also proud of it
like I thought it was listen so here's
the thing with me I think everything
that I do is awesome and it sucks every
time so if I make something like a new
video that first video I think it I
think I think it's awesome like I think
wow I did this video it's amazing look
at this it's a great story I told it
this is great and wow that sucks so much
still now
I love the videos that I'm making I love
my channel I think I think I think I
deserve a Nobel Prize for my channel I
think it's that great I think it's the
best channel on YouTube I think it's one
of the best things in the world ever I
think you need to be proud of the work
that you do and I think I think the
content is changing lives you know it's
awesome
and I feel like I'm just getting started
like everything I'm doing sucks and
needs to get so much better
so I you know if I want to hit 10
million subscribers or a hundred million
subscribers I need to do a lot more work
and I need to get better me personally
my research team my editing team
everything is to get way way way way way
better so I think people often just lean
in on the eye socket art some people
lean in on the I'm amazing but their
stuff actually sucks and I think it's
helpful to have that that both sides
that you know I did the best I could I'm
really proud that I stepped up and I did
this and I recognize that it sucks and
if I keep going I'll get better what do
we have Salima Evan do you follow any
routine before you make a video do I
follow a routine before I make your
video so yes if I'm thinking about the
ones where I'm more involved in so like
the insta presto series as an example
where I have to get up and do a mini
speech alongside I try to watch the clip
so I mean I always watch the clip I got
to see what I'm what we're talking about
and then I try to see what I think about
it and not just try to agree with
what the person said but what is my
perspective usually it's pretty close
but sometimes it challenges me to think
differently Sadhguru is an example we
had a couple ones he had some
interpreters that we did where I just
had a hard time digesting the message
it wasn't that I flat-out disagreed with
him although I did for Robert Kiyosaki
and one of them it's just being you most
of the time I agree with the message and
I give my own take on it so I'll watch
the clip I'll think about what I want to
say sometimes it'll be the night before
now so the night before I'll think about
what I want to say I'll usually write
out the first sentence like what's my
opinion here's what I think about this
video one sentence and then some point
form notes and then I get to the filming
and I just I just go I'll say the first
sentence and then I'll hit some of the
notes I won't hit some of the notes I'll
look at it quickly before I go on but
I'll just I'll just go that's normally
what I do I try to also think about you
guys I think about the audience think
about the people watching and that this
is important I think in general the more
you could think about what you're doing
is important matters I think it's hard
because a lot of times which is by
ourselves if you're making a video you
just talking to a camera you know you're
in your home when you're in your
basement or you're in your garage and
you're working on your business it's
hard sometimes to think that what you're
doing is really important but if you're
especially in the communications
business if you're making videos or
making content it's really so important
that you feel like what you're doing is
important I was having a conversation
with with a speaker the other day who
he's got a he's got a great message he
really does and he's already moving
people he said but you're you're doing
on another level I said the only
difference between me and you is that I
have conviction with what I'm saying and
that I just feel the importance of more
and so if you took that approach for the
rest of the day like it's almost noon
for me here for the rest of the day if
you said the rest of that this day's
matters is important I'm gonna do work
that's important I'm gonna show my
grandkids this work it's important that
I'm here
you're gonna create amazing stuff just a
lot of us we're not working hard enough
right we're not we're not really pushing
it we're not really feeling like we're
giving everything because we don't think
that it's important enough you might be
asking well Who am I to create something
important
you're a genius that's who you are now
get out and make something important
like make today count when are you gonna
wait what are you waiting for next week
next year like let's go
you're genius go make something
important so I think that really makes a
difference next me high/low Evan how are
you I'm great thank you how are you got
got chiku how long how long have you
been looking for yourself
I don't know that question means next
omnia how to own a charisma and
principle of formation I want true
stories as simple people in life Wow I
also don't know what that question means
guys if you clarify I'm happy to try to
answer it quickly Lukas hi Evan I run an
Instagram blog on which I promote
Scotland as a tourist destination hey
Carmical is a Scottish clan we have our
own tartan so I'm I'm already a fan here
although I've never been to Scotland one
day I need to monetize in order to grow
but I'm nervous about leaving a bad
taste with my audience
any advice make sure that you're doing
things if you're this is on Instagram
I've run an Instagram if you're do an
Instagram then then you're not selling
ads you're promoting product right is
whatever is gonna be in your link in
your bio make sure it's something that
you firmly believe in I think it's the
biggest piece of advice for anybody
who's trying to sell their community
you know when I'm marketing and talking
about my book I believe in the book like
it's gonna help you for specific
problems you know you're trying to find
your your core value like read your one
word you want dealing inspiration read
the top ten rules if you want to learn
how to biohack like neither these are
gonna be helpful for you right so
figuring out what you're selling and why
it's really important matters I think
most people are selling stuff they don't
believe in and that's why it also makes
them feel vulnerable feel unhappy feel
like they're cheating people
and so I think a lot of people get into
the business for the wrong reasons
they're just trying to make money they
don't care if it works or not if you
really show that this thing works
so like why Scotland what are you
selling are you selling
you know Scottish flags you're gonna
sell tourist trips there you're gonna
sell maps or guides or something once
they're there what is it that you're
gonna sell and it has to be something
you believe in most of the brand deals
that I get from my business I turn away
cuz I haven't used their thing I'm not
gonna talk about your product if I'm not
using your product you know we have say
John as a customer and and Stephen Kelly
and I get on usually once a month and do
a hangout for you guys I use sage like I
used them for my accounting software in
my business I can talk to you about how
I use H like we can go through it
together I can look at your numbers and
help you I like that you know I don't
want to work with companies that I can't
get behind their product there's another
social media company that helps you
manage your all your social media
channels and an activity called Agora
pulse that reached out to me you want to
do something and I'm I'm trying it now
it's like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
talk about it and recommend it unless
we're using it and we're getting value
and we're getting benefit from it so I'm
on it my teams on it and we're seeing
the results so if you look at your
Instagram page you know you have your
link you have one link to promote
something I would make it count I make
sure that whatever it is that you're
selling you firmly believe is gonna help
the people who are showing up what do we
got posh posh notions we are important
exclamation that's right you are I just
talked to my best friend and on a whim
came up with a great idea to share our
stories without moms so thank you for
your great advice all right all right
glad I could help thank you so much what
else we got what else what else what
got you how long you've been looking for
yourself again I don't understand what
that is but I appreciate you from Russia
and you have bad it's not biting let's
just just add a couple more sentences to
it and we see we can get it done on time
razmik have you ever felt desperate who
and how do you and how you dealt with it
have I ever spell felt desperate I'm
sure I have it's been a long a long long
long long time I think when you're
desperate you do stupid things I think
it can force you into some some
potentially you know resourceful things
but you can also make you do stupid
things I think the reason why I'm not
desperate is because I lean so hard on
gratitude I think you can you can always
feel like you're desperate right now I
could feel like I'm desperate everybody
in the chat right now could feel like
they're desperate but if you are
grateful for what you do have and
recognize that compared to 99% of the
world like you're probably way way way
ahead then you don't feel as desperate
so whenever I feel I think a sense of
lacking is helpful you know like I want
to hit ten million subscribers on
YouTube but I'm not desperate to go out
and do it I want to do it in the right
way and I'm so grateful for the 1
million that I have I think it's just a
choice like I think that by by you
thinking that some external thing is
gonna change it and change your
desperation then you're wrong because
then you're gonna be desperate for
something else it'll be this endless
cycle like it's never enough we always
want more that's part of human nature
and I think it's good I think that leads
to growth I think that leads to
contribution and impact like me wanting
to hit 10 million subscribers means I'm
providing more value to you guys you all
get the benefit in the in the growth in
the journey as well
but when you get to desperation I just
don't think it's a super healthy place
to be on a regular basis and so I would
I would try to swap it for some
gratitude and recognize this was part of
what doing these stories of these
successful entrepreneurs means for me is
that so many times these people came
from absolutely nothing and it just
makes me so appreciative and grateful
for what I have that like I'm
complaining about this thing in my life
compared to what other people have to
deal with and just the fact that you're
watching this chat and you have you have
internet access puts you ahead of most
people in the world so gratitude that's
the way out of desperation Jay Rhys
clarifying gotchas question Evan when
did you first know you wanted to help
entrepreneurs okay um I first knew when
I had I was invited to go do some
speaking around it when I sold my first
business I was invited to do speaking
and I got invited fate where my first
event was I spoke in Mexico I spoke in
Brunei I was doing some international
stuff kind of young successful
entrepreneur go share your wisdom with
other young entrepreneurs and it was fun
and what made me think there was I want
to do something in my country to like
why why do I have to speak in Mexico in
Brunei why can't I do something in
Canada and so I approached the YMCA a
local YMCA and said hey I want to do
something and I felt this story a number
of times but you know we promoted this
event only three people showed up and I
was saddened at the beginning when I
walk in and only three people were there
but it made me realize that you know
these people showed up I'm gonna I'm
gonna give my best for them and it was
awesome I think that was it like that
was the day recognizing is in the past
the other events I spoke to a big was a
big audience a big group and it was
really fulfilling but when I went to
speak to the group of three people
thinking that it would be way bigger
right thinking that would be a packed
house and only three people showed up
and I still did it I still loved it made
me really feel like I have to find a way
to keep doing this even if
even if I never make any money doing it
it just makes me feel good so I'm gonna
keep doing it and that explained it two
more seminars to eventually website
eventually videos so I think that was it
Salima Evan are you open to meeting your
fans in person on Wednesday at your
studio yes
I've actually posted it on my Facebook
page if you look up
I live in Carmichael on Facebook you'll
see we have one next week actually
so I shoot in in a mall right Colonel
den salsa is one of my businesses and we
shoot in a mall and people say is that a
green screen no like that's actually
trying to dine salsa and so we tried
this last month and we had people come
in and they kind of waited in the hall
while I'm filming and I pop in and out
every now and then in between in between
sets they come say hi take selfies and
some questions go back in so it's a test
last month was the first test it was
awesome and so we're gonna try to keep
it going every month if I'm filming at
TDS so if you are in the Toronto area or
want to come the Tron area last last
month a guy was came from the US had to
get his passport just for this so some
people went through more Herculean
efforts and others to show up but was a
lot of fun and so if you are free
anybody next Wednesday come on by TDS go
to my facebook page you'll see it's a
free event you don't have to no payment
you can say that I'm coming and I look
forward to seeing you there and we'll
try to keep it going on a monthly basis
when I do my filming guys it's already
noon crazy how quickly one hour flies by
thank you for the love I hope this
session was helpful for you we got to
answer some questions I really really
really like kind of as a final message
hope that you take the rest of today
whatever time it is for you whether
you're just getting started where you're
about to wrap up make the rest of today
count do something really important do
something that is meaningful even if you
only got an hour left before you go to
bed you still have an hour left before
you go to bed you can make that mean
something to yourself and to somebody
else make that important and then carry
that energy through with you for the
rest of the week as well thank you guys
so much of the love I always appreciate
it well we have a fantastic close to a
week I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love guys I'll see
you soon